but then we also do these mobile teams
two reception centers like this where uh
and as you probably know today today we
reached 4 million refugees from ukraine
but
i observed also at the border with
poland
it's not like before now fewer people at
this moment are going out of the country
is a very fluid situation
some people
maybe come to see their relatives some
people go to other countries some people
stay in poland is a very fluid situation
because i think everybody is watching
how the war is going
we are telling
the donors giving the money to us or the
european union or the governments be
flexible because maybe we need more
resources in ukraine maybe we need more
resourcing in poland it's a very
we need to be ready for any movement in
this very difficult situation
[Music]
we were already because of fuel prices
food pricing shipping costs beginning to
cut rations for
millions of children and families around
the world in countries like let's say
yemen where we had just cut eight
million people down to 50 rashes and now
we're looking to go to zero rations
niger mali chad and i could go on and on
and on so now we're talking about a
catastrophe on top of a catastrophe
because ukraine from the breadbasket of
the world now to breadlines we never
would have dreamed anything like this
would be possible and it's not just
decimating
dynamically ukraine in the region but it
will have global context impact beyond
anything we've seen since world war ii
the people that have made it to the
outside to three and a half to four
million people and one way you can say
they're the lucky ones because they are
getting food they're getting shelter
they're getting help they're getting
some degree of hope out of harm's way
but you have 40 million people
40 million that are inside ukraine
and we've got to do everything we can to
stabilize the food supply chain system
and reach as many people as we possibly
can because you can imagine
the farmers
are on the front lines fighting
and it's planting season for corn maze
right
now foreign